Salut les mentalos ! Aujourd'hui on va parler de l'analyse transactionnelle.
A la fin de cette vidéo, vous serez en mesure de mieux gérer votre temps, parce que vous allez mieux comprendre comment il découle.
Cette théorie, parce que c'est une théorie, elle a été fondé par un psychiatre dans les années 1950, qui s'appelle Éric Berne.
C'était un psychiatre qui est né au Canada, et qui ensuite a vécu aux Etats-Unis.
Et à cette époque, tout le monde se disait c'est le nouveau génie, il a raison, il avait raison sur plein de choses, peut-être pas sur tout, mais ça c'est un autre débat.
Eric Berne décide alors de construire sa propre théorie.
En regardant les liens qu'il y a entre la structure psychologique et la communication.
Et là ça devient très intéressant parce que tout l'enjeu de sa théorie, c'est de prendre conscience en permanence de qu'est-ce qu'il se joue, maintenant, au moment présent.
Entre nous et les autres, c'est une évidence, mais aussi vis-à-vis de nous même.
Vis-à-vis du fameux "JE".
En découle donc 6 structures du temps qui passe, d'un point de vue relationnel vis-à-vis des autres.
Donc le fait de les connaître ces 6 structures, ça nous permet d'en prendre conscience, de les étirer, de les resserrer,
de peut-être en enlever au bénéfice de choses plus productives ou justement pour plus se détendre.
Avoir conscience, c'est avoir le pouvoir !
Première structure, c'est le retrait, qu'on soit tout seul ou dans un groupe.
C'est le fait de se mettre en discours intérieur, d'être dans ses pensées, soit dans l'imaginaire soit en train de réfléchir.
Un exemple très concret, c'est quand vous arrivez au sein d'un groupe d'amis, que ce soit au travail, ou en cours quand vous êtes en cours,
vous vous posez avec tout le monde, sans forcément dire "bonjour".
Vous êtes avec eux, mais vous ne leur parlez pas encore.
Soit vous écoutez, soit vous êtes dans vos pensées.
La deuxième structure c'est le rituel.
On passe énormément de temps à faire beaucoup de rituel, ça n'apporte rien à l'échange, ça n'apporte rien au relationnel, ça n'apporte rien à la conversation et ça n'apporte rien dans notre rapport avec l'autre.
C'est comme ça.
C'est les "Bonjour !", "Bon week-end !", "A la semaine prochaine !", "Passe de bonnes vacances !", "Bonne année bien sûr !"
"Et toi, ça va ? Oui, moi ça va et toi ça va ? Oui ça va."
Moi aussi ça va !
Troisième structure, qui apporte énormément de choses, elle par contre au départ, c'est celle qu'on appelle le passe-temps.
Comme son nom l'indique, non, elle n'apporte pas grand chose.
C'est le fait de passer le temps avec une personne qu'on ne connaît pas ou peu.
Ou  des fois qu'on connaît mais dont le lien, le feeling, ne permet pas de faire autre chose que le passe temps.
Alors on va dire que les anciens parlent de la pluie et du beau temps.
En vrai tout le monde le fait, même les jeunes.
On va parler de ce qu'on a mangé hier, on va parler de ce qu'on a fait hier alors qu'il ne s'est rien passé de vraiment terrible.
On va parler d'un fait d'actualité un petit peu basique, dont tout le monde parle en ce moment...
Ça c'est la structure du passe-temps.
Quatrième structure, c'est l'activité.
C'est celle qui va nous permettre d'atteindre un but, un objectif que ce soit amical, que ce soit social, que ce soit dans le travail, que ce soit sportif, que ce soit...
Peu importe !
Si par exemple j'échange avec quelqu'un pour qu'on puisse voir à faire des choses plus tard sur la chaine et que du coup on essaie de se trouver un rendez-vous, un lieu, une date...
Là on est en plein dans l'activité.
L'activité, c'est pas forcément celle qu'on est en train de pratiquer réellement,
c'est déjà le fait de parler et de discuter, de se donner des choses à faire, de se répondre...
Ça c'est l'activité, c'est très important.
La cinquième structure c'est le jeu.
Et dans le "jeu", J-E-U, il y a le "je" J-E.
Ce n'est pas le jeu en terme de loisir, ça on le mettrait plus d'ailleurs dans l'activité.
Ce sont les jeux qui obéissent à des règles précises, relationnelles, transactionnelles, qui sont souvent néfastes.
Puisque chacun a un rôle déterminé et il y a quelqu'un qui peut souffrir de ce jeu.
Et surtout le jeu va se répéter entre les personnes tout au long de leur vie, jusqu'à temps que le schéma soit cassé par l'un ou l'autre.
C'est fait de non-dit, mais pourtant il y a des règles très précises en dessous.
C'est quelque chose que l'on voit beaucoup en politique.
Il y avait quand Jacques Chirac...
Olala !
Qu'est-ce qu'il est jeune Fabien ! [rires]
Quand Chirac s'était présenté aux élections présidentielles, il était face à Mitterrand.
Duquel il avait été ministre à l'époque.
Donc ils étaient en débat, d'égal à égal.
Et Chirac avait précisé à un moment donné, je ne me souviens plus exactement des mots,
mais comme il était candidat au même titre que François Mitterrand, il n'avait pas à l'appeler "Monsieur le Président", il pouvait l'appeler François Mitterrand.
Et ce à quoi François Mitterrand avait répondu: "Mais tout à fait Monsieur le Premier Ministre."
-Nous sommes, deux candidats.
Vous me permettrez donc de vous appeler Monsieur Mitterrand.
-Mais vous avez tout à fait raison Monsieur le premier ministre !
Et là on voit exactement de quelle manière Mitterrand avait humilié Chirac dans cette phrase.
C'est un jeu de non-dit, mais il y a un jeu quand même qui s'installe.
C'est comme si je faisais tomber mon stylo à répétition pour que toujours la même personne le ramasse,
tout en sachant, en le ramassant, que je l'avais fait tomber exprès mais qu'elle n'ait pas d'autres choix que de le ramasser.
C'est ça qu'on appelle le jeu.
Donc si vous passez plus de temps à être dans le jeu avec une personne que dans l'activité, ce n'est pas une bonne relation.
Peu importe de quel coté vous êtes du jeu.
Et enfin, l'intimité qui est la meilleure relation qu'on peut avoir avec quelqu'un.
L'intimité encore une fois, c'est au sens large du terme.
C'est toutes les relations que vous allez avoir avec des personnes privilégiées, où vous vous sentez accepté, elles se sentent acceptées aussi,
c'est tout à fait épanouissant pour les deux.
C'est la base des relations qui sont franches, qui sont loyales souvent, qui sont directes, qui sont précises...
Il n'y a aucune ambiguïté.
Et il n'y a pas besoin de grands échanges verbaux pour ça.
Par exemple, il y a quelque chose qui vient de se passer devant moi, qui m'a beaucoup fait rire,
et je vais tourner la tête vers quelqu'un qui est près de moi avec un sourire, et je sais qu'il aura compris pourquoi j'ai ce sourire, et je sais qu'il sait.
Ça c'est l'intimité.
Je vous invite vraiment à retenir ces 6 structures, je vais vous les mettre dans le descriptif.
Je vais vous mettre aussi des liens pour ceux qui veulent aller un petit peu plus loin dans l'analyse transactionnelle.
Et déjà, dès maintenant, vous pouvez vous poser la question de quelle est la structure la plus présente dans ma vie.
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe le plus et le plus souvent.
Si vous avez des doutes sur votre structure liée à un échange, vous pouvez le mettre dans les commentaires.
N'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à le mettre et puis moi je vous répondrai, je suis sur que d'autres aussi passeront pour répondre.
Mais on peut en parler ensemble, juste là.
Et une fois que vous serez aguerri à savoir qu'est-ce qui se joue, quels sont les enjeux qui se passe à chaque moment, et à chaque échange avec quelqu'un,
alors vous serez capable de régler ces échanges là, plus facilement.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, j'espère que ces échanges là entre nous, vous auront plus.
Si c'est le cas, vous pouvez laisser un pouce en l'air, et ça c'est gratifiant.
Pensez à vous abonner avant de partir, pour ne pas rater de vidéos, pour ne pas avoir de retard puisqu'elles sortent vite, puisqu'il y en a une par jour.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !